the attacks in Brussels and Paris
exposed shortcomings in Europe's fight
against terrorism but new rules and
procedures seek to give greater powers
to Europe all the European Union's law
enforcement agency Robert de sá porphyry
bientôt se puede conseguir neutralizer
en términos de prevención y tambien
neutralizer en términos de repression
Valkyr organic a young criminal aqua kir
attented o contra la salida de los
teléfonos european news specialist units
are to be set up to tackle new forms of
terrorism they will have the authority
to request information from for example
facebook to trace terrorist
propagandists stronger cooperation
between national police forces will also
be encouraged mep s have ensured all of
this is underpinned by democratic
safeguards it's very important that you
have a very solid pace of data
protection in the rules
in accordance with the new legislation
and and it is also very important that
we have parliamentary scrutiny on the
whole institution which is also new and
it's also involving national parliaments
these new rules will come into force
from may 2017